un Memorial para los fallecidos del 19
los brasileños rinden homenaje a las
víctimas de la pandemia los habitantes
de Sao Paulo escribieron mensajes en un
mural edificado en una Avenida del
centro
creo que es importante que rindamos
homenaje a un momento que fue tan
importante para la vida de muchas
personas y más ahora con las elecciones
estamos recordando a todos los que
tienen su nombre escrito aquí a todos
los que perdieron a alguien a todos los
que se fueron Brasil reporta 680.000
muertos es el segundo país con mayor
número de muertes relacionadas con la
pandemia después de Estados Unidos
bolsonaro Fue muy criticado por su
gestión del covid 19 entre otras cosas
comparte teorías conspiratorias y
minimizó los riesgos relacionados con el
virus también rechazó el uso de la
vacuna veo compañero
mi compañero probablemente habré vivido
si la vacuna se hubiera comprado en
septiembre de 2020
durante la campaña política Lula usó
ampliamente el tema para criticar a su
adversario
tú mentiste sobre la vacuna todo el
tiempo y le quitaste importancia a la
vacuna y Brasil tiene ahora el título
del país que tuvo más muertes por Kobe
es lamentable
bolsonaru por su parte siempre dijo
tener como prioridad a la economía con
reflejos de pandemia y una guerra que
golpea a todo el mundo Brasil va en la
dirección correcta por el bien del
pueblo gracias a los recortes Fiscales
récord y a la responsabilidad social del
gobierno el país respira mientras el
mundo camina en una recesión y
desabastecimiento históricos a pesar de
sus declaraciones bolsonaro fue acusado
por la comisión de investigación del
senado de Brasil de crímenes contra la
humanidad por su gestión de la pa